Les pourparlers entrepris avec
l'animal n'ont jamais débouché
sur des solutions concrètes pour
résoudre le problème des odeurs.
- C'est dans cette usine,
à Rivière-des-Prairies, qu'on
apporte la grande majorité
morceaux de viande rejetés
par les abattoirs pour les
transformer. Une activité qui
est loin de passer inaperçue.
- C'est comme l'odeur
de cadavres, là. Mes portes
restent fermées et mes fenêtres
aussi, parce que sinon l'odeur
rentre à l'intérieur
de la maison.
- En été, là, ça pue beaucoup.
- La Communauté métropolitaine
de Montréal veut régler
le problème avec un nouveau
règlement sur la pollution
atmosphérique qui encadre
les concentrations d'odeurs.
Il doit être approuvé par Québec
avant d'entrer en vigueur,
mais Sanimax veut convaincre
le gouvernement Legault d'en
retarder l'adoption. Sa survie
en dépend, affirme l'entreprise
qui s'est d'abord confiée
au quotidien Le Devoir.
- Je ne pense pas que ça va
me faire de la peine
si Sanimax est parti.
- Une perspective qui cause
de l'inquiétude dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui envoie
ses sous-produits de porc
et de poulet chez Sanimax
pour qu'ils soient transformés.
DIMITRI FRAEYS v-p innovation
Conseil transfo alimentaire Qc.
- Si l'usine devait fermer,
bien ça aurait comme impact
qu'on devrait rediriger
cette matière vers les sites
d'enfouissement.
- Le nouveau règlement
interdirait l'entreposage
de matières animales à ciel
ouvert et obligerait Sanimax
à construire un garage pour
accueillir les camions qui
viennent décharger leur
marchandise, afin d'éviter
la propagation des odeurs
dans le voisinage.
L'entreprise se dit ouverte
à construire un garage et a
d'ailleurs pris un engagement
similaire dans ses installations
de Lévis, mais estime
qu'un délais de 18 mois est
trop court pour y parvenir.
Au Cabinet de la mairesse
Plante, on déplore que
des discussions, qui se sont
échelonnées sur deux ans
et qui ont pris fin l'été
dernier, n'aient pas permis à la
Ville et Sanimax de s'entendre.
"En aucun cas la Ville n'a eu
entre les mains un plan complet,
incluant des solutions
et technologies permettant
d'atteindre les normes en termes
de qualité de l'air
et de l'eau", indique-t-on.
Le gouvernement Legault analyse
toujours le règlement
de la Communauté métropolitaine
de Montréal. Enter temps,
tant la Ville que Sanimax
se disent prêtes à relancer les
pourparlers, conjointement avec
Québec, pour dénouer l'impasse.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Mon